I think because it's been woven into my
mind since I was a child and there was a
I remember one of my first Christmases
it was it was on the television and it
was this phenomenal thing that not only
looked incredible and was exciting but
it seemed to have real depth mysticism
to it and I can't really believe that
I'm in that they created their own
worlds which is very particular and very
beautiful and was copied plenty of times
but never really succeeded in finding
the magic that they have and it's a huge
honor and a little bit scary then to try
and take it on yourself it's bit mad the
way that we that they did this one that
JJ made everything very tactile and back
to kind of what they when they were
originally working on it that felt kind
of impromptu in a way that were kind of
a bunch of people isolated somewhere
kind of doing their own thing kind of
outside the studio system and even
though that's not really the case here
it still felt that kind of that sense of
everyone was making it up as we go along
and still felt urgent and tactile and
and like to see everything being
practically operated and puppets and
everything you could just pick up and
hold I think was was more exciting and
shooting it on film I think that was
that just made it even more I had a bit
of a moment coming here in the car when
I realized I hadn't really taken on
board that I was in Star Wars and I
thought perhaps I should have done some
thinking and preparation to lead me to
this moment so I'm looking forward to
not fainting in Hall H I know Oscar went
to a something similar previously where
there were a lot of the fans there and
he said it was just extraordinary the
love for the film's in the room was a
kind of Baltimore so I'm just looking
forward to that but I've no idea what to
expect I don't really know
did say that there's people can can't be
on since Wednesday night and that then
you've kind of like well we better say
something good yeah just makes it more
sure yes no I think she came came to
comic-con when I was four years old or
something about like four or five and I
don't really remember much as boxes of
box of comic books and it's kind of
evolved into this what we're doing right
now I guess
but as far as the fans reaction to it I
think it's a testament to the movies
that not yeah the artistry and whatever
making it but also that they left a lot
of things open-ended in the movies where
I think now people feel the need to
explain everything or everything kind of
has to add up but there's so many worlds
that were kind of that people kind of
took ownership of and made their own
stories and I think that made a more
personal just such a wide group of
people
my first Comic Con was last year and it
was a word that I use a lot it was
overwhelming the amount of positivity
and warmth people have towards you and
it's so rare to be in an organized event
where everyone's so happy and so pleased
to see it for me and I'm you know not be
YouTube I live my life
you